first of all it is wonderful to meet you
guys the film was absolutely incredible
and i know that you two are both you
know very seasoned actors i grew up
watching you know both of you on
television
but
taking a character that you've played on
television to film
what is that process like because
obviously you've done projects on film
and projects on television separately
but is there sort of a what's the
process like of taking a character that
you've played especially for you know 10
years to film it it's not hugely
not hugely different because the tv
series is quite cinematic anyway it's
got the big landscapes it's got the big
houses it's got some breadth and it's
got time to breathe
um so it isn't
really from our point of view i don't
think any different from from making the
the television series
it's shorter and sharper so you have
less you you've got just as long if not
longer to film the scenes which is great
but
the the whole experience is is shorter
and therefore in a way sweeter because
if you're doing something for six months
it you know it's more tiring but if
you're doing it for six weeks or two two
and a half months it's it's more like a
you know oh we're doing this you know so
there's that it's a speed dating version
which is always more fun because it's
compressed entertainment for too long
don't look at me when you say that madam
and this film is sort of a culmination
of a lot of years of storytelling
particularly when we get to the end you
know and the dowager countess passes
away and particularly you jim you have
this wonderful scene where you you found
out she passed away and then carson
quotes king lear sitting at the servants
table when you've played a character for
that long who is who's been in service
to the dowager her entire life what was
it like to sort of play that kind of i
guess grief
well
it was so very easy to do really because
um
you know carson has had a long
relationship with the dowager countess
and jim carter's had a long relationship
with maggie smith and uh you know the
thought of
her passing uh
you know is is desperately sad i mean
you know because she
in a way is you know she's the uh the
embodiment of the old spirit of of
of downton
and carson
is also an embodiment of that spirit and
so with two pillars of of
rectitude and uh tradition really and
then one of the pillars has crumbled so
it's it's very easy to
to play especially when julian fellas
gives you a bit of shakespeare which
yeah you know because he could write as
well yeah and you've done kingly in the
past as well haven't you i have yeah
i've never said those lines but i've
done i've done did that on film with
anthony hopkins but yeah yeah and you
raquel um one of my favorite bits of the
film is sort of the end we get to the
end and mr mosley proposes to miss
baxter
what do you think their wedding would
look like do you know oh um well i think
i would get some lovely hand-me-downs
from lady cora she would see me right
certainly
um
everyone would be there it would be
i mean we've had one of those we've had
servants weddings before so there'll be
lots of dancing we did the village hall
didn't you know
um
what's my wife's called um what's your
wife calling yeah
yeah oh that's right
what's it logan phyllis no what's she
playing what is it
oh um
oh my god
i'm blanking on it oh no zero completely
blank
mrs hughes
is what's your first name and everything
yeah yeah
yeah we've done the village hall so
you'll have to come up with something
different i think we'd probably model it
on
maybe you'll have a marquee on the
grounds
maybe yeah and i'll be very disapproving
as long as you're there disapproving it
will all be right
it'd be sweet it would be family
and you you um you've worked with your
wife in melistan in the past but you did
get a very very sort of brief scene in
this film and obviously you said you
know it's sort of the speed dating
version of working on something versus
television but what was that like you
know getting to work with her on a
project that you've been attached to for
so long well once i got over the shock
of her being in it you know uh
it was a couple two or three years ago
she said oh i've got a script and i said
what is it said downton abbey you can't
be in that i mean that and i was furious
that she was playing an upstairs
character you know rather than the
downstairs character once i got over
that it took about 18 months
um it was very nice you know i mean to
do that little scene in the hat shop
which was filmed in healing studios it
wasn't in the south of france at all of
course you know but uh yeah it was good
in the cheeky line about you know i was
being married at the end of it so it was
good fun you know it's always and it's
nice to have a holiday in the south of
france together so that wasn't too
shabby either yeah well thank you both
so much it was wonderful meeting you
okay nice to meet you
you